hopefully most of you have made some
decent ground in putting your component
graphs on there this is just a simple
song so I don't need to flip any of them
upside down and pad but- or anything
like that but the shapes are a lot more
interesting so it becomes a little
trickier than think about this now again
I'm going to start this one the way I
started that one which is to look at the
easy bins first look at the parts of the
graph where you don't have to have any
graph right on this when you have a look
at your components there is community
discontinuity where is it it's an x
equals 0 okay now discontinuous I got
asked a great question before about how
do I need an open circle okay you could
put an open circle on there if you
wanted but what you'd have a look at why
it was 1 on X it has no open circle why
is that because instead of an open
circle we would put an asymptote there
right the places where you put open
circles if you were graphing something
like this y equals x squared X now I
think we a bread sort of triggers oh I
better simplify that and so you just up
pops y equals x in your brain right but
this is not my equals x because there's
a discontinuity do you see that right so
because it can't exist at 0 when I draw
this I would say almost everywhere this
thing looks like y equals x like all the
way off that way and all the way off
that way except at that one particular
point where I get the denominators being
0 right so that's where you get a whole
this circle cuz you're like oh I'm
passing through it looks like I should
be passing through but I actually didn't
you know okay that's what the hollow
circle indicates in this case no hollow
circle required because no one in their
right mind thinks oh I'm not here like
the asymptote tells you when you're gone
ok all right so I've got that just
smiled in my mind what else can I
conclude from this graph and how will I
do it any suggestions
yeah yeah so one of the obvious things
that we look for because they're easy to
work with is points of intersection now
I've drawn this I've done the best with
my scale but I could that point of
intersection actually because of the
simplicity of these graphs you should be
able just look at and see what's the
point of intersection it's not 1 isn't
it right because x equals 1 or you
square it you still get 1 you take the
reciprocal
you still get 1 so therefore at x equals
1 the whole graph is going to be y
equals 2 I've added those coordinates so
it should be twice as high right now
that was a spot on the right hand side
where they sort of equal each other so
they dr. is a sort of equal and opposite
side on our feature on the left over
here can you see one of these is always
negative what is always positive so that
means there's some point where the
negativeness of this is exactly equal to
the positiveness of this where is it a
textbook was negative 1 because you
square it and you get one and you take
the reciprocal and you get negative 1 so
when you have a look I guess based on
the scale that I have used it'll be
something like that and you can actually
if you draw yours like really awesome to
scale you can literally just measure and
sometimes we have no choice because you
don't have enough other information ok
that's good we've got some important
points what else can I do here to help
get a shape any suggestions ok yeah
great idea so addition of ordinates if
you're adding two positive things
together they're gonna get bigger I
think
right so whatever the real graph is over
here it's gonna be above both of these
all the time does that make sense
so I'm going to get this shape up here
and I'm going to get this shape up here
does that make sense you can see over
here on the left if you want to imagine
it this way you've got the hyperbola
right that's kind of like the thing
that's taking over and then you're
adding these little
it's from the parabola so that's why
you're getting closer and closer and
closer does that make sense but then
when you go in the opposite direction
you're actually um having a parabola
take over and you're adding literally
two bits from the hyperbola you see that
okay so that looks good so far there's
actually a problem with it but we'll
find out what that is in a second
generally it's pretty good
what about over here it's happening 4x
is less than zero okay so over here it
depends on what where you're starting I
suppose if we want to start negative I'm
gonna look in here see this spot here to
the right
this guy is positive but it's not very
positive is it it's like little
positives whereas this guy is negative
and it's super it's massively negative
right so if you're thinking that
tug-of-war again this guy's winning okay
so therefore I'm gonna get a curve down
like that and it's important that you
notice I'm getting closer and closer to
the hyperbola why is that important
because the thing I'm adding to the
hyperbola is getting smaller and smaller
smaller so this value is the gap down
here okay what happens when I go further
that way yeah I'm gonna approach this
guys because the hyperbola is getting
tired and for example so therefore the
concavity actually changes did you see
that concave up concave down so you
actually would put inflection somewhere
in there okay now we're pretty much done
except I mentioned before that there's
actually a problem with my graph
remember I said he Hey stationary point
okay there's a stationary point here too
and you can actually find out what it is
how do I find out what stationary point
is you're just differentiate you
wouldn't we've done mr. Dettman Tina
cross right so there's the function okay
let me just write it in a way that makes
it
easier to differentiate us okay so if I
find the first derivative what would you
like me to write good that that is the
derivative okay I guess I can write that
a little bit neater okay cool
so why was I doing that for you I'm
looking for a stationary point and by
the way just this is a take off my
extensions you have put a my tune and
extension one half because I see this
all the time please don't just stay on
the next line like oh that's just make
it easier but it is equal to zero
sometimes well actually specifically one
time but not always right this is a
general statement of the derivative
everywhere that's the whole awesome
thing about differentiation and if you
want to say I'm finding stationary
points then please say that like
actually tell me what you're doing for
stationary points the derivative is zero
okay so now I can go and solve this
looks like this what I'm gonna do
there's a bunch of different ways I
could proceed with the working I'm going
to get this guy over TR and then I'm
gonna multiply and divide this swap
things around get all the X's in one
spot so that's going to leave me with X
cubed over here and 1/2 over here so
this means that this is 1 on the cube
root of 2 which I think you'll find is
about point eight that go ahead your
calculator will tell you okay so point
eight point eight where is that in
relation to this time what was there
what was the x value again for this one
that was one right so actually much
stationary point is just a little bit
this way so that's how I knew and
actually possibly there but the
stationary points actually a little bit
oh yeah point seven nine four was what I
worked out before okay your calculator
can confirm that for you okay so does
that make sense when you can find out
important features you should intercept
sup obvious ones
now I'm feet
almost done let's finish this off by
adding some of those asymptotes that we
kind of knew were there but we didn't
draw the bin where's the EZ asymptote
it's really obvious one X equal zero
right you can see that of dances that's
all good okay but then there's this
other asymptotic behavior which is kind
of related to the parabola do you see
that so in fact in reality y equals x
squared is an asymptote okay that's a
bit weird for us because it's too unit
and extension winston's we've only ever
encountered straight lines there were
asymptotes but an acident is just a
theme the curve approaches and that's
what it does right in fact you could say
not only are you as applied to x equals
0 you can say you're asymptotes to the
hyper but if you wanted to it's true you
you approach both of those do you see
because they are all kind of squeezing
in together